before we begin since this is a bbc
owned property i feel the need to point
out that the news arm of the bbc has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pin comment below various
videos from both myself and other
youtubers covering this issue and while
i understand that the doctor who
creative team is not responsible for
this i will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
i really hoped i'd come away with a
better overall perspective on this
series
[Music]
well finished my re-watch on series 11
which means it's time for me to
rank them
so
yeah like i said at the front end i'd
really hoped to find more to love and
like i found
bits i softened on some episodes but
then there are others that i now found
more problems with than i'd had
originally and others where i did know
there were problems with them but they
were bigger than i thought and having
now a more complete look at chibnall's
time seeing the start of a lot of what
will become recurring problems made this
a difficult re-watch
really
frustrating
because i want to like it i wanted to
like it first time i saw it i wanted to
find more to like in my re-watch
i i kind of didn't
but i gotta rank these anyways although
this time i am gonna
flip the order
normally i start at the bottom i work my
way to the top this time starting at the
top we're going down the reason is
well if you've been watching these you
already know what my number one is there
is literally no surprise to be had there
and honestly i probably have more to say
about the ones that are going to show up
at the bottom uh at this point
but
let's not stall anymore
let's start at number one
it takes you away again if you've been
watching these shouldn't be a surprise
because yeah i said flat out favorite
one of the series one of my favorite
ones of the whitaker era it's not
flawless none of these are but
it brings a level of weirdness that i
not only love i want from doctor who
more in general not just during tribal
time like i want this kind of weird
more because doctor who can get this
weird but does not very often and i love
the vibe i love the sort of sense of
foreboding that we get early on and then
the sense of just weirdness later on and
that it culminates with the universe
presenting itself as a frog and it just
wants a friend
yeah is that absolutely
freaking nuts yes
yes
and i love it
number two
[Music]
demons of the punjab
i get uh some of the issues with this
one as well there are a lot of nuts and
bolts things that don't quite pull
together here however this thing
to me
nails the one thing that it had to get
right if it was ever gonna work
and that is the characterization and the
emotional core of the story being told
and of the guest characters they're all
well performed it comes across as
believable the conflict that is dividing
them and the situation just feels much
more emotionally honest
than
a fair amount of doctor who can not even
just restricting it to this era it's
quite well done in that respect
there's some issues in other areas but
this is truly one of those cases where
if you get the one main thing right
i at least are gonna i'm gonna cut you
some slack because when i evaluate these
things i don't i'm not dividing it up
like a test score it's not like well you
got this many wrong and this many right
like no the simple fact is is that
with an episode like this when the thing
it needed to get right
is working
that's what's going to stick with me
and the issues while they exist
they fade away with time
and even after a re-watch the issues i
have with this are already starting to
fade from my mind and what's left is a
strong emotional core with believable
characters and this delivers that
number three
[Music]
yeah i know i know i went off on this
what's bad about it is
really infuriating but this is a case
where it doesn't nail the thing that it
absolutely had to nail because it's
trying to criticize uh capitalism
and just doing it really ineptly
however
the simple fact is the vibe and the
energy
the sense of propellant motion the sense
of adventure and also again very well
shot this one
that does count for a lot now when i
watched it the first time all that stuck
with me so much that i didn't really
grapple with how messed up a lot of its
messaging around capitalism was
especially at the very end which holy
crap does that ending
absolutely fall apart but at the same
time
i can't ignore the fact that
everything that i liked about i liked so
much i didn't even notice that stuff the
first time and even on a re-watch while
i'm noticing it now and yeah is
it's real bad
that energy isn't gone
that
sense of
impending doom that sense of
oppressiveness in the warehouse that
sense of trying to unravel the mystery
of what's going on i think the setting's
good i think the um overall atmosphere
is good i think most of the guest
performers are good i mean charlie i
feel bad for the actor because the
character's written terribly but a lot
of the core components of this are good
and do work and the overall energy to it
i really enjoy this has the feel
of something that i like from doctor who
even if the actual specifics don't hold
up
number four
[Music]
the ghost monument
kind of a similar deal to curblam this
has a vibe and an energy that i really
dig i actually don't think it falls
apart as hard as curblam does in terms
of its weak uh elements its weak
elements are more sprinkled across the
whole thing whereas curblam completely
falls apart at the last hurdle and i
debated back and forth what order to put
these and honestly if you asked me
another day i might have switched them
around but ultimately the reason i did
them in the order that i did is that
with curblam the things that i like
about it i like more than the things
that i like about the ghost monument
even though the things that i don't like
about the ghost monument i have less of
an issue with it than the stuff with
curblam so it's like it's they are
really neck and neck but again the ghost
monument has an energy that i enjoy it
has good guest performances there is a
when when this era does sort of
propellant stories like this like
curblam it does them quite well the
sense of energy and the chase and the
trying to get away from stuff and trying
to stay safe
i enjoy all of that
again there's a lot of nuts and bolts
stuff that doesn't hold up there's a lot
of the specifics that either don't make
sense or feel underexplored but
ultimately what i'm left with when i
think back on it is
i liked the energy of that can we have
more of that energy with just a tighter
script
number five
[Music]
rosa now my relationship with rosa is
complicated and i've talked about that
in the now
three videos that i've made on that
episode um however overall i think
i've softened from my issues with it my
issues with it were very rooted in stuff
i was going through at the time and
while i don't think my concerns or my
read on it were invalid i don't feel as
strongly about them as i did before and
as a result i am gentler on this episode
and the actress who plays rosa is
honestly really good and i don't really
have a problem with kraskow as a villain
there are some other elements that feel
a little bit off a little bit contrived
i still feel like the
uh closing doesn't quite land right it's
not as off as i remembered it being but
it's not landing quite right i hate that
there's no consequences for what ryan
did to crasco that's still
so bizarre to me but this isn't
necessarily an episode that i came to
find a new appreciation of but it's more
one where my criticisms don't feel as
pressing it doesn't feel like
the things that i took issue with before
they're not as rooted in me and as a
result the stuff that i did remember
being good
is shining a bit more on this re-watch i
think that's why this lands where it
does
number six
the witch finders this one actually this
and rosa it was another kind of back and
forth i flipped them back and forth a
couple of times now the witch finders is
actually
notably better than i remembered it
being it does
quite a bit with its initial setup with
capturing that sense of paranoia of
people turning on each other and
alan [ __ ] is just having a blast king
james isn't especially well written but
he's exceptionally well performed so
he's still fun even though the character
isn't that great on paper he brings a
lot to it
however this does fall apart
real bad at the climax not in the way
that kirblam did i.e undermining itself
but justina completely losing the thread
because up to that point up to the r the
actual full reveal of the morax they had
a perfectly serviceable human villain
she was working really well as a human
antagonist that was fitting to the time
into the circumstances and now suddenly
not only are we dealing with mud
monsters but they also kill the human
antagonist it would have been one thing
if the mud monsters and her were both
around for the for the very end and the
doctrine communities had to deal with
both but no
they basically just take over the
villain slot and we don't know anything
about these mud monsters so we get this
big lure dump and it's a techno babble
solution and it's a mess it is a mess of
a conclusion and while i said it doesn't
undermine itself quite the way that
kirblam did at the same time the highs
in this weren't as high as the heisenker
blame again
what what i liked about curblam i really
like but then it
kind of
it's knocks its own feet out from under
it whereas this while i think it's much
better than i remember it being
it doesn't astound me and then with the
ending falling apart as bad as it does
it just leaves me going oh oh that's
kind of a shame
number seven
[Music]
the woman who fell to earth
it's fine
that's kind of all i've got there's like
little bits and moments and some of the
character introductions
are pretty good but it just it feels off
still
and in some ways that i'm able to put my
finger on in terms of the way the doctor
is and sort of her getting on her moral
high horse at a few points where it
doesn't quite track or make sense to me
with my normal understanding of the
doctor and they haven't established her
well enough for me to understand why
she's kind of doing or behaving or uh
approaching certain things the way she
is but we also have good moments she has
a you know decent banter with the
companions she has a nice speech at
towards the end grace is great i still
say there wasn't really a need to
kill her but you know it's fine
it's fine
that's just kind of where i'm at i don't
really have strong feelings about it i
don't think it's that bad
but unlike
basically everyone that i put above it
those i can at least point to some parts
and go that part was really good though
they it needed more of this or it would
have been great if just x hadn't
happened whereas this i'm just like it's
it's fine
i can't tell you what the exceptional
strong aspect of this is because it's
just fine
number eight
[Music]
the saranga conundrum
and
this one just doesn't have
a lot of positives the stuff that's bad
in it honestly
i think this might be an over maligned
episode because the stuff that's bad is
not
that bad there just isn't very much
that's good
really the only thing of note that felt
good to me was the interactions between
the doctor and the uh head medical
person on the ship before he gets
ejected into space and removed from the
story and other than him
there just isn't
much that's good
the monster is this tiny unintimidating
thing and it doesn't even really quite
work as an irony where like it looks
cute but it's dangerous it isn't quite
clicking for that
with the way that it's shot designed and
the way that they're reacting to it as
performers
it's just overall
just
kind of a nothing
of an episode i can't even get that
worked up about it
it exists
number nine
[Music]
arachnids in the uk
pretty sure this was my bottom first
time i
went over this because i was just i was
it
didn't strike me as a great idea in the
first place
but it also just did not need the
political commentary it was so shallow
and so dumb and chris nothing was stuck
with playing such a garbage character
yeah
you know it doesn't help that we're kind
of learning that chris nothing isn't a
great person either but like that's a
separate issue this just
it isn't good
it's giant spiders it's it
it's schlocky
in a way that doesn't quite work like
doctor who can do
camp sometimes but this isn't really
camp this is schlock
and there's a difference and i don't
like when doctor who does schlock
because camp can work like i like robots
of sherwood that's a campy episode but
this is just
this is just low-grade b-movie
garbage somebody
just tossed it aside and thought well
maybe that could be a sci-fi original
movie concept and they went oh we'll do
a doctor who episode no
think better of doctor who then doctor
who deserves better than a plot like
this
and then again with the
warped morals with the fact that the
doctor is always planning to kill these
spiders by suffocation and then gets
uppity when the dude shoots them doctor
you were always planning to kill them
and some would argue suffocation is not
particularly humane so what the hell
much like saranga conundrum there's
almost nothing that works here but
unlike that which just leaves me going
here the things that don't work actively
annoy me
but it doesn't get the bottom spot
because that
regrettably
goes to
number 10
[Music]
the battle of iran's core avcolos
yeah
the finale is the worst episode
that's a rough place to be
it's it's hard to
feel excitement for the show to come
back when you end it on such a
damp squib
of an episode there's a handful of
concepts that are interesting but
nothing is done with them and i suspect
they were stumbled upon by accident and
because they're not core parts of what's
going on the whole idea of the planet
like messing with people's heads sending
out these psychic waves or whatever
doesn't matter it's just there why who
cares
it's got the same lame
underhanded uh not understanding what
faith actually is approach to faith that
i've railed on for science fiction for
doing before it tries to have payoff
with graham with uh simschat but like
that doesn't work as far as graham
having an arc and simcha was not a
villain worth bringing back he's got an
intimidating voice and a little bit of a
gross look that's literally all he has
going for him this is driven by a
combination of coincidence and idiocy
and poor mark addy he's doing his
damnedest i even kind of like him in
this but it's not because the script is
despite it
this is just
so
limp
and weak
and the concepts are half-baked
underdeveloped don't mean anything this
isn't a culmination of the series this
isn't going out with a bang this isn't
even going out with a whimper this is
going out with a
which i'm pretty sure was the noise i
made when i did the review
this
boy
for me this series didn't start out
great
but then it got better
and the second to last episode i think
is the best episode it has and then it
ends with the worst
and
it is kind of close between this and uh
arachnids in the uk and honestly what
maybe tips this into the last spot is
the fact that it is the finale if this
was the middle of the series
i still wouldn't like it
but it wouldn't feel like such a waste
the fact that it is the finale amplifies
everything wrong with it
how would you rank this season what
order would you put these in whatever
your thoughts are drop something down
the comments let's talk about it
patreon's what pays the bills enables me
to do this for my living any amount you
can give is of immense assistance but
even if you can't there's other stuff
that i do that you can check out in the
description of this video like share
subscribe also help me out hit the bell
if you feel like it but don't worry too
much about it
because at the end of the day
what i want you to remember
is you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you're the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
hey end credits time which means i need
to shout out some patrons this time i'm
going to be shouting out robin moore
zubin lutfalla turak oliver b melinda
walters imudelki the oath the boy tt for
knobby lax the poodle zach paul idolin
tracy scrapbot vincent paul bartolucci
angry casper toku b.l hovian adam rdl
taylor shane ross shaylee gourlay and
brendan larose you want to hear me
mispronounce your name check out rewards
on the patreon
thanks for all your support
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]